test. There we go.
Got to love software being awful.
Like that never happens. But somehow
because it hardc crashed my PC, it
screwed up my device settings.
Mute. Now it should be good, right?
Yeah. Good.
Stupid morning man.
uh software just crash as always.
Have you guys not noticed in the last
year that like nothing has been working?
I mean across many machines and many you
know browsers and whatever like basic
web pages just do not work the way that
they should.
Stuff has just been super bloated and
crashy for no reason.
am I working on?
Uh if we can get the web server back up,
I will show.
We are currently doing mostly
integration and maintenance work leading
up to the big 5.0 release. We have a
whole bunch of new environments.
buffer 3D in it will be I need to fix it
up.
That's actually on the That's like the
to-do but not super important list. Like
I got to do it before release, but it's
kind of whatever.
This is weird that this doesn't work
now.
I have no idea how difficult that is.
Sounds like that the physics with that
would be quite annoying.
All right. Whatever.
Let us
hopefully test all the ends.
I honestly I'm a little
I don't know with the website if we want
to set a a limit or something.
We definitely need to limit the policy
size to some extent of what we're going
to be on the uh what we're going to have
on the website.
I don't know if it's worth trying to do
BF-16 weights or not.
I mean, we could make some improvements
to the inference for sure, but the
startup time with loading the weights
Uh, so I I moved the 5C stuff onto 50.
So it's now 50 because that is the
actual dev branch for the release. So
there are no more name changes to the
branch. And it's not too late to submit.
Um, you'll see as soon as I have this
open that all of the ends that were
submitted have actually already been
pulled in and I'm debugging them now.
Like that's exactly what we're doing.
Why the hell I This doesn't make any
goddamn sense, does it?
Stupid thing, man. What I get for using
an old PC that still has Windows on it.
Never again, man. Native Linux always.
It's just so bizarre, man. I don't even
know how Windows like how it manages to
have this right? It's probably
just some jank from WSL. Hell.
What? WSL is total I agree. I
thought it was good for a while until I
spent two days trying to track down a
perf issue that was just straight up WSL
leaking 25% perf for no reason.
Like I genuinely do not understand how
Microsoft as a company has any value
whatsoever.
Hang on. This is not smooth yet.
We will fix it. This is the whole point
of this like stupid LLM setup that I
have here is just there are 50 ends and
like I need to be able to very very
quickly triage because it's going to be
basically the same three or four bugs
for every single end.
PR finally submitted
uh light bike.
I like Tron. You mean this?
Oops. Where is it?
This
I'm going to change the uh the
background color like the outer
background color to match puffer. Other
than that, it's good.
Policy is not bad.
probably improve it.
That was fast.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm pulling. You just happen
to submit it on the day that like I do
like this is literally the day that I'm
handling the last six months worth of
NPRs.
Yeah, I'll show the double pendulum.
We'll fix it though. I'm thinking we
might do like end pendulum or something
since that was a big Twitter thing. We
might just add that. It may or may not
be useful.
fixing double pendulum. Let's see if it
works.
Not quite. It looks like you can play
with it if you'd like.
You see how they're just like a million
stupid little like port things to
address?
This would normally make my life
miserable for a couple of weeks every
release,
which is why we're doing this.
craft decks is basically Yeah, basically
that
Colo model is 755K.
Oo, that's nice.
That's definitely nice.
Vibe coding, not vibe coding.
This is maintenance work.
Docking puzzle. This is nice. This is a
solid end.
You see how there just like a million
stupid little issues with everything.
Okay, this is pretty funny, isn't it?
It's like It's Flappy Puff.
I actually like the way that they tilted
the puffer.
That's super funny.
Oh yeah, there have been there have been
like a ton of different flappy ends.
Some of them have been like very low
quality and not worth merging. I just
like randomly picked one of them finally
and said, "Okay, we'll see if this one's
any good.
invert. Is this vibe coded? like the
nothing's aligned here on the rendering.
Basically any of these ends if you like
them and you think that they would
actually be useful for research like
just start playing with them and see if
you can train something interesting.
Pretty much any of these ends, if it
ends up being useful for research or
producing something interesting, can
become one of our most commonly used
ends.
I've decided to introduce this like gold
silver system where we mark our best,
most stable, most useful ends as gold.
We mark the ones that are like have
potential as silver and the rest of them
stay blue.
Nope. No bronze.
I don't need two tiers.
I mean, I only need two tiers.
Everything else will just go in our
default cyan. That's the bronze, if you
will.
Flappy Puff. No, gold are ones that
we've used. Like there's also a
requirement for golds that we've
actually used them for a while in active
research and we know that there isn't
any weird jank associated with them,
which all of these fit. You see,
Also, I'm not going to gold um I'm not
going to gold tons of simple
environments. So, like we have breakout
pong and cartpole.
Many of the environments that just
instasolve unless they look really
really cool or have some other property
associated with them. I'm not going to
gold.
Imagine
doing all this work manually. Yeah, I
did this work manually every update and
it was awful.
Um,
now when we only had like 10 or 20 like
10 even 20 m, it wasn't that bad.
it's such a classic thing.
I kind of just needed to pick a couple
sanity check ends, right? Like you
should insta solve pawn cartpole and now
with the latest puffer breakout.
All three of these are under a second.
Arguably we could swap it for something
cooler.
Maze has been one of Maze and 2048 are
my top two. Like I use these and
breakout for quick test. I use these
more than anything else.
Neural MMO has a massive new soda
because we fixed a big OBS bug
Hey, look at that.
This is the super easy version of it, of
course.
X.0. You should update them. Yeah.
You'll notice I also I kind of just
stopped doing minor releases because
it's just too much work.
I prefer to work on major cycles.
Weirdest jank you've seen in an Oh my
god. I've seen every possible thing
under the sun, man.
actually neural MMO the bug that we had
with this one it was still learnable and
it could still be superhuman but what
would essentially happen is let's say
that you can observe another player it
would essentially ghost the rendering in
the observation so that like you see the
entire trail of where the enemy has been
and you have to keep track of like which
is the current one versus which is the
smeared rendering of the past
and it could still get superhuman with
that. It just took a ludicrously long
time.
NPC shuffle. Learning the pseudo
randomness of NPC shuffle when stepping
under.
Wait, there's no way it learned the
PRNG. Dude,
you just put a spam click in the center,
don't you?
Elatro soon. Looking forward to it.
Does it come with any sort of um
self-contained rendered or does it have
to hook into a copy of the game?
Because if even if you have like just a
minimal self-contained render, we can
stick it on the website.
I highly doubt the creator is going to
be like, "Ah, you're ripping off my
game." Like nobody's going to actually
play the version with no like with just
like box graphics, right?
I had implemented it way too
deterministically.
I'm working on uh chinning another
account at the moment on the side screen
here.
94 ranged.
Now, what's solid is uh freaking two
code eyes, ancestral hat, and two prayer
scrolls in the last 50 raids.
I'm a little worried about whether I'm
going to have like full gear to be able
to do um archives on release.
Sold T-Bo. Oh, I wouldn't have sold
T-Bo. Geez.
like the one thing I've like never sold
and always kept since I bought it
cuz like all my favorite content uses
T-Bo
one or two megas
better to have one or two instead of max
max. Yeah.
Oh yeah, the drop rate changes.
I really wish they hadn't done that.
Like, yes, I'm profiting off of it
because that's what I'm doing at the
moment, but
I think that they definitely
they try to like they cater way way way
too much to irons. Like the only way
that stuff holds value long term is if
the average person like doesn't ever get
one of everything or more than one of
everything.
Like I would have honestly been down if
they just made the deck scroll like 5x
rarer from the start.
Just holds like 200 mil value
permanently.
Yeah. I I find it very stupid that they
like it's an like the thing that makes
MMOs cool is the economic balance that
you get by having designed for having
lots of players and having to make
everything solo completable just ruins
it. Cuz
basically, if everything has to be solo
completable, eventually everything just
dips in price because too many of them
come into the game.
Auto aggressive action space
each step conditioned on the previous.
Ooh.
um
that can work if you formulate it
cleanly. It's a little gross because it
extends the credit assignment horizon.
Um multiddiscreet is very nice if you
can do it. Multidiscreet is very nice if
it can do it. For stuff that's really
too complicated to just multidiscreet,
then yes, we do have conditional like
singlestep conditional action generation
in progress for net hack and chess at
the moment. I will say,
okay, so all of this stuff is in
progress.
Wasted so much time figuring out
invalid. Yeah, without masking that'll
happen.
He arked a double pendulum. What was
wrong with that crit?
Is it the if statement that assigns a
reward if you actually solve it?
Look, if solved assign I just removed
the if statement.
Oh god. The worst actually the worst
like the worst fail I've ever seen with
language models
was when I was working on Soabon all day
and then Bet just came in like, "Yeah,
I'm going to get chat GPT to sell this
watch." And it's like, "Hey, look, I got
99% on Shookon with Chat GPT or
whatever." And it's like, "Yeah, okay.
Let me see the policy." And it had just
removed or was it Maze? It wasn't Soon,
it was Maze. Yeah. And it had just
removed all the walls in the maze.
Reward was set to zero in C reset.
That's fine.
You The reward can be set to zero in C
reset, right?
Unless it's being Oh, I see what you
mean. Ah, okay. Yep.
What site is this? This is the dev build
of Puffer.
So, this is where we host all of our
demos.
Agents run around in your browser and do
things.
This is probably one of the cooler ones.
They'll run right in your browser.
You can see we have a bunch of ends
here. And in the next version, we have a
bunch more ends.
Who did Dr. Mario again? I remember that
was like a new contributor who was like
super excited about it and couldn't get
it to work.
This is all open source. You can help us
out for free by starring the puffer on
GitHub. Pufferfish love stars.
We actually probably should just have an
RTS game on here if you think about it,
right?
Wait, has actually has nobody submitted
an RTS to us yet?
That's actually really surprising to me.
I guess the action space for an RTS is
really annoying.
Well, okay. The closest thing we have
like it depends if you want to do RTS at
the level of like one agent controls all
the units or every unit is an agent, I
guess.
How much for Gro sub? I ran out of
tokens.
Um, this is the $300 a month sub. That's
Well, I got it at 100 a month for the
first three.
I have not run out of tokens yet.
Um, if I start hitting usage limits
though, that's when I get annoyed.
I absolutely should not be hitting um
usage limits on a $300 a month plan
doing routine maintenance work.
Like this thing is not even really
writing much of or any almost any code.
It's basically just fixing little tiny
things.
Oh yeah. Isn't that Kinvert?
Kinvert does have Command and Conquer.
invert has a lot of ends.
If I can convince him to have them all
polished.
If he'll actually like take the time to
polish them, by all means.
The thing that like people have to
realize, right, if you just want to like
dick around and make some random end to
learn, that's cool. But like the ends
that we end up using for research are
the ones that people actually finish the
last 10 to 20% of, right?
Like it actually has to be fast,
polished, simple, good code.
Heck, even I'm guilty of this. Like Moa
here, this is an awesome environment and
it just needs a little bit more polish.
Okay, this framiness is the stupid
language model things up. I'll
I'll sort that out in a second.
This is fixed at least except the
policies are bad, but the uh the
rendering is fixed.
Weekly electric fish.
Yeah, I know it's the hardest, but like
you got to finish your projects, right?
Honestly, like what's the difference
between me and like everybody else who
started their own little reinforcement
learning library? I kept doing it
market in the world.
What happened after GPT?
Um, my hope for RL is that the impact of
it is much more directed. like you're
not going to see a ton of big
generalpurpose systems powered by RL,
but you're going to see very important
domain specific applications in a
variety of areas that you indirectly
really care about like in scientific
simulation
um for medical discovery um you know
biological sim probably in material
science you'll get quite a bit of impact
on the science side from that uh you
will see it in games like you will just
have RL agents in games and that's going
to be super fun and cool. I'm hoping
that it gets done or I hope I'm hoping
that we're able to be involved with that
frankly in a way that's like actually
fun and something that gamers want and
is not just like shoving the new stupid
tech down everybody's throat.
I think it definitely can be something
fun. Um,
other than that, obviously you're going
to see it in various places in robotics.
I think the type of RL I do is
specifically way cooler for things like
drones and for um like low dim control
than it is for humanoids.
But I've always sort of thought
humanoids are kind of stupid. Anyways,
is that subscription X premium? No, it's
Gro Heavy. It's um it's separate.
You do get like basic Grock or whatever
with your X Premium Plus, but um I got
the full thing because it's fast.
Honestly, the biggest thing that they
could do to improve it in my mind is
just make it 10x faster.
Like I don't foresee anytime in the next
year, like couple years, I don't foresee
me going, damn, actually it's just smart
now. I think we're still going to have
all sorts of really stupid errors. Um,
coming from these things like that
doesn't mean that they're not useful,
though. And the thing that makes it most
useful is if it just does it all faster.
of Valve CS2 cheating. Um, it wouldn't
really be for anti-che as much, frankly.
RL Pac-Man.
Oh, like this.
Where is it?
Where's Pac-Man?
We have it on here somewhere.
Here it is.
Do they have the charts published
anywhere? Val, if they have like the
benchmark and token speed versus
drones plus RL are kind of scary.
I'm not opposed to defense tech, but if
I come up with like the coolest thing
ever and we can't figure out anything
better to do with it than like blow each
other up, then we kind of deserve that.
Um, I think we can do much cooler things
with it, though.
Honestly, what my maybe it's naive, but
my hope for drones with uh like military
drones would be that like they just get
good enough that there's no point in
fielding human soldiers. We kind of just
destroy each other's drones and then
when somebody runs out of drones, it's
like, "Okay, let's call it.
on medium matching opus 5 at high.
Okay, I could probably try that.
It did that by default.
Is it necessary to complete classic ML
final year? Ah, so if you want advice if
you're learning um AI stuff here, I
actually do have like good formal no
advice.
these two articles will be very useful
to you. Um I don't think that most
classic ML is super necessary to be very
familiar with. You should have at least
some sort of historical back background
so that you don't do something like you
know throw Bert at a problem that's
obviously just bag of words. I have seen
students with no background before do
that. Um
I I personally am not very
mathematically inclined. My math is
mediocre at best.
You obviously need to understand back
prop. probably should have written some
kernels or at least some like layers in
numpy by hand um and understand how that
works.
That actually does come up. But aside
from that, I generally find that having
a good background in systems and just
low-level development in general is much
more useful than going heavier into
math.
Want to Okay,
you had so long to eat.
How do you earn? Curious.
So, all of Puffer stuff is free and open
source. Uh, we have the fastest by far
RL tools out there. We have some of the
best algorithms as well.
We build ultra higherf Sims. Companies
can pay us to build them high perf sims
or to generally integrate our tech with
their internal RL efforts.
So it's pretty much we build the best
stuff, you can use it for free, but if
you want to have the people who build
the best stuff making sure that your
stuff actually works, then you can pay
us for that.
It's something of a groundbreaking
business model in this age. Imagine
instead of it being software as a
service, it's just service as a service
I've always thought that that's
basically just a streamer game mode
anyways, right? It's like
eh
it's more than consultancy.
Consulty would just be like, "Hey, I
know things. Hire me." Right? This is we
actually build all of the tools.
the blood tova.
Oh, hardcore man. A hardcore volo.
No, blood tor is cool.
What does typ There really isn't much of
a typical day to be honest. Depending on
what I'm doing, it's either going to be
infrastructure dev or building sims or
doing core algo research or occasionally
you get like this where it's
just, hey,
it's time to release the next version
soon. And this is essentially
semi-automated or mostly automated
janitorial work. Um, just making sure
all the the new M's actually work.
I figure I can automate about 80% of the
work for this. Um, just like the
janitorial work. And then I'm pretty
much just going to have to go through
all of our high quality M, make sure
nothing got messed up. Um, and then any
Ms that are like suspiciously not
training correctly in the new version.
Slay the spire like game
while works as a play tester
to a certain point.
Yeah. So, I mean the main advice I have
for that, right, is you got to make the
game stupid stupid fast,
which is not hard. Like, if you're just
writing your own game from scratch,
lowlevel and see or whatever, it's
actually very very easy to get a,000x
the performance that basically everybody
else targets.
Just nobody bothers to do it.
Um, and then when stuff is very fast,
then you can do stuff like, "Oh, yeah.
I'm just going to train my RL agent on a
millennia worth of gameplay from my game
on one machine."
Oh, look. It really likes exploiting
this combo. Hm. Let's nerf that.
Vampire survi ver uh survivors is not a
great type of env because there really
isn't much to the gameplay and it's a
spectacle env. So you can't really make
those fast because the whole point of
the game is just cramming the maximum
number of entities possible onto the
screen before the computer blows up.
So it's not interesting as a learning
problem and then it's also like annoying
from a systems perspective
just no no bullet hell actually bullet
hell there's actual mechanics too you
can dodge stuff right like if you wanted
to make like a Toho style end you
totally could do that.
Um, vampire survivor style env is
significantly worse than like a Toho EN
wrote the whole game engine.
separate logic from visual. Visual logic
has no overhead. Yep, that's the correct
design. Good job.
The other obvious common ones are like,
can you get it to be zero memory
allocation after initialization?
It depends what plan you get.
I'm using it because it's fast.
Okay, I've kind of just been stalling
talking to chat here because I went
through and I gave this literally 30
different minor end fixes to do. I don't
know why this thing doesn't do like
doesn't just kick these out to sub
agents automatically,
but this will be done pretty soon
anyways.
Yeah. A while ago, even before Fable, I
just stopped even considering the
anthropic models on principles. Um, I
just no longer want to give those people
money.
Um,
and then overall
it's kind of funny to me how close
um, like Codeex and Grock are given the
like given the head start that Open AI
had. It's kind of pathetic frankly.
But hey,
what are you going to do
from Reddit?
What on earth of my thing is on Reddit?
depends what C++ code base is. That's a
mixed bag if there ever was one.
I honestly would not be surprised.
Like I like for for the Gemini models, I
genuinely would not be surprised if the
models are literally worse if you train
on Google's code rather than if you
don't.
Like maybe they're better at solving
tasks, but I would not be surprised if
they just write way worse code.
I've never looked at Chromium, the
Chromium source.
They're on GitHub now.
Oh yeah, I genuinely do not know why the
hell they bought curser.
more issues.
Let's take a look at uh let's take a
quick look at some of these
The dlopify prompt. I think I committed
it to the 50 branch. I've still been
playing with it. It will not just like
suddenly make the dumb model smart, but
if you if you throw it at really
code, it does a good amount of the like
initial stuff for you.
Okay, we'll just do this in passes, I
suppose. Oh, here's a snake. I think
this policy sucks.
Once I have your env.
Yes, man.
I have a bunch of maintenance to do
first.
Look at all these ends.
Right.
Well, I haven't been able to stick like
yours is the only one that I can't put
on the website, right? Because it's
CUDA.
This is laggy as hell,
but that's probably just the
Huh.
That's better.
Yeah, that's definitely way better,
right?
I can't play that. Well,
that's actually really good.
Holy crap. Look at that.
That's a very precise game.
Asteroids P. I think asteroids could be
a very nice um like medium difficulty
arcade end for us. The only thing that
makes it slightly annoying is I do think
you need the entity encoder.
Okay, there's the policy.
Oh.
Oh, that's an exploit. But we lose. Why
do we lose every other point?
Like every other point we lose. It's
weird.
Oh, there it is. There's the towers.
Oh, okay.
I Yeah, I don't know about the defaults,
man.
End of needs a little work.
Our fish simulator. The policy is not
very good.
Can you merge double pendulum? Yeah,
we'll do. Let me as soon as this thing
finishes, I'm going to do the next round
and I'll do that in uh in that pass.
Just remind me.
Oh, this looks so much better.
There we go.
I'll specify every one of these sub
agent afterwards.
How do you do variable length stuff?
Variable. It depends on what?
Like variable length. What? Obs.
Like what's in the obs? If it's variable
length
say entities.
Yeah. Then you zero pad and then um it
doesn't really matter. The zero padding
should just get ignored in the work.
you a team. We have a big open source
project and Spencer works on this with
me full-time as well.
I actually don't know what he's doing
this weekend. Probably doing some
Robocode stuff.
He's worked super hard in the last few
weeks though on stuff. So, I'm kind of
happy to just be
doing some of the maintenance
the minimal like the reason I say it's
minimal should auto solve
Do you sort the obs? So the best thing
to do is use an entity encoder.
Second best thing to do is to sort the
obs.
Our entity encoder is pretty good
though.
It's kind of new.
I think I'm going to use the restroom
real quick. And then what we're going to
do, we'll do another round of these
updates, but this time I'm going to make
sure it actually paralyzes them
correctly because otherwise it's pretty
awful.
second here.
on puffer from a plane. Are you working
on flying a plane with puffer from a
plane?
That'd be good.
financial markets.
Uh yes, we've done work in finance and
commerce professionally.
other than maybe policy. This is good.
M is good.
Craftex is kind of the one that I need
to figure out more manually.
I don't really know about overcook to be
honest.
This needs some work probably
What M have you rated so far?
I just have kind of added like our
standard ones to the gold set here.
Volley
slime volley is going to end up being
gold for selfplay at some point.
Yeah, slime volley is really nice
because it's easy to get like a pretty
strong scripted fast uh opponent.
because it gets confused and it
forgets to split everything out into sub
agents.
Like I'll say, "Oh yeah, use sub agents
for everything." And then two messages
later it forgets.
This is way better. See, this is the
minimal end.
I actually really like this boss fight
environment.
Uh oh. Please tell me Discord doesn't
crash my PC.
That'd be very sad.
There is a tower defense and that's new.
Apparently Carmarmac's at RLC.
That would have been cool to meet
Carmarmac.
messages.
Cool.
All right. Cool. Let's do
Let's do this. We have
Oh, wait. This thing can just run 19 sub
agents apparently. I thought you were
limited to like 16. Nope. Apparently,
you can just literally run 19 sub
agents.
this will finish everything. We will
check everything again.
The part that I'm not looking forward to
is the part where I actually have to go
through all the code dips for everything
and just say like, "Nope, that's
ridiculous. Stop breaking all my nice
end of code." Blah, blah, blah.
And I accidentally just pulled out a
handful of eyelashes.
Oops.
release
this week.
Oh, not released this week. Pre-release
this week. What am I talking about?
new 5 though. have to pull like the
actual new 5 cuz I basically I I moved
slash rename/deleted old 5 and now it's
on the new one.
I would certainly discourage Daario from
saying that ever again to anyone.
mobile Viz Dota.
Do you recognize the map? The map is
actually just the Dota map.
Like, this is literally just loading in
the Dota map. The characters obviously
aren't.
We just came up with five characters
that were loosely based off of a a
combination of Dota and League
abilities.
It's a really cool end. We need to do
more with it. I think we're probably
gonna polish it up uh and do some more
with selfplay on it once we have our
selfplay stuff set up and prevent you
from doing stuff like phasing through
small walls.
I mean, there's some cool abilities like
there's an assassin character that has a
blink strike, you know, the tank has a
big pull like um
there's their healing abilities. There's
like a bursty mage with a big AoE.
There's like a couple of them have buffs
as well. I don't think there are any
dots.
think we did any like dots though.
It's not everything everything
obviously, but it's like a good range of
different abilities and stuff.
So much as an Well, it's a very fancy
game and they keep updating stuff,
right?
Oh, yeah. This is actually just Dota,
didn't you hear? This is the new texture
pack. Yeah.
No.
Oh, this is so much better now, right?
That it does all 19 things in parallel.
Like, we're already We only have seven
things left.
I basically just gave this thing access
to an 8GPU box to cue jobs on for
anything that needs retraining. And um
everything else is embarrassingly
parallel. So, you played League? I've
played a little bit. Volo, I'm terrible.
I'm bronze at best. Iron more likely.
Okay.
Is Grock bot or normal Grock?
What?
Whatever the normal Grock build thing is
WF battle convert freeway. Look at this.
This is like six different ends right
now that are all just running their
jobs.
Type crock and seal. Exactly.
Lo gets it.
He'll climb hack and make RL history.
Um,
hey sir.
So, uh, you know we have an intern,
right? And where is he?
We do have an intern.
And
he's got soda by a gigantic margin with
puffer on net hack.
It's actually one of the M's I am most
excited about.
There's no 4X. I think we would be
better served with like an RTS, but even
then, um it's not that the game itself
is hard to RL. It's the the action space
is just really obnoxious to set up.
Yeah, I Finn's agents have both gotten
higher score and gotten farther into the
game by far than any other like any
other AI, including to my knowledge the
scripted ones that won competitions in
the past.
which is very nice.
In fact, that's what I would like to be
doing right now instead of all this
maintenance Maybe that's what
we'll do. We'll finish this and then my
reward will be on Monday. If we finish
everything, I'll get to just play around
with net hack,
smaller model for hill climbing.
So, Net Hack is uh you can look up Net
Hack. It's a crazy hard game. It's also
not at all hill climbable, by the way,
which is the funny thing about that
comment. It's like the least hill
climbable thing imaginable.
Hey, there's the man himself. Finn is
the one who we were just talking about.
Net hack. Finn has been
completely smashing it.
All
right, Finn, check this out. All right,
this is my local view.
Look at all the new ends.
Look at them.
What are the odds that we can get Net
Hack to run in the browser? Is it zero?
I'd love to just be able to deploy your
net hack agent in the browser and just
be like, "Yo, Tim,
I would like it to be not needing Python
and crap to build at least."
Also, all these screenshots are updated.
I've been making visual tweaks as well.
So, like lights out looks way better
now, right?
This fixed.
Yep, this one's fixed.
Okay, this has the bug where everything
moves in slow motion.
No, it doesn't actually. It's literally
for some reason everything is just what?
Oh, it is. Yeah. Yeah, it's the slow-mo
bug.
One sub agent remaining.
Well, we'll wait on this and then we
will uh we'll do all of them at once.
Oh, there we go. Look, there's the
battle end.
Oh, it's this converter is the one that
it's still working on. Oh, yeah. This is
our minimal uh our minimal entity
encoding demo.
I like it.
Sometimes just making stuff go fast is
also kind of cool.
It's like, did you know that RL goes
fast? Even though even though we can run
it at a thousandx uh this speed,
what's the latest on net hack, Finn?
We also have not like chatted in a
while. So, by the way, like you can just
ask me for a meeting whenever you want.
Um, I leave it open to you whenever you
want to actually like bother, but I am
here to answer whatever.
So hopefully you learn lots of stuff
this summer in the process as well. And
any knowledge I pretend to have, I can
impart.
Implementation optimization.
It's a pretty good mix, I'd say.
I really wish that I got to spend more
time like implementing ends at the
moment because that's a lot more fun.
I get really sick of all like the AI and
maintenance work and I kind of just want
to jam some sim code. much more
enjoyable.
All right, let's just let's refresh
this. And well, there's only one task
left. So, let's see.
Just let me do one thing on the side
here.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I honestly think
that the single roll was mostly just
because people couldn't get multiroll
working before. Um, if you can train
multiroll and it's not a massive penalty
to learning it, you should always do
multiroll
and then you can just report the
breakdown.
Lots of results. Oh yeah.
Lots of results.
pole.
Basically just spot checking all these
ends. You see?
Oh, that's so much better, right? Yeah.
I think we're going to have to cap the
size of the policies that we deploy to
like something that just doesn't lag
because I don't like I really don't like
it ever when Puffer lags. You know, we
have the highest perf stuff out there
and if we have to ship slightly smaller
policies to keep our website super um
like super smooth, we should just do
that.
It's embarrassing to be shipping laggy
crap.
That's a little big cuz 4 mil 16 megs
that might be okay if we get BF-16
working to be fair
but mind you that doesn't mean we're
going to cap all of our policies for
experiments fan that just means for web
demos like we will ship a slightly
weaker policy. See?
Okay, everything is running smoothly at
least.
Policy sucks.
Okay.
The problem is having to support touch
that adds a bunch of code for every
single environment.
So, that's one of those features where
I'm just going to be like, unless it's
for an end where obviously it makes
sense. No,
I just be like, no, we're not
maintaining that.
2048 maybe for 2048.
See that? That's like a Okay, that's a
maybe reasonable ask, right?
Connect 4. We might have to like make it
terminate one step early so that it
actually renders the final state.
That falls into the realm of more minor
things though to deal with.
We're not there yet.
Wacka- puff.
Flappy puff.
Okay. The shape of the puffer is
actually really satisfying. The way that
they did the rotate on it,
it's actually really satisfying.
Okay. Yeah, the bot can add the touch
controls, but then I have to go wade
through whatever mess of code it makes.
Like, code is not free.
Particularly not when you're adding it
to literally our most important
research. En
Can I exchange a soup voucher for a
code?
Unfortunately, most of the things I do
are either free or very expensive.
I find all of the stuff in the middle to
be not particularly worthwhile.
This may have potential. I don't know
the game.
I'm going use the restroom while we get
these um these fixes in. Okay. And then
uh this should be basically be the first
pass fully done, which is pretty damn
nice to have this all ready.
Get back.
Oh, is Grock doing the coding here?
Really? What co What code is Grock
writing then?
Uh, what what code do you see Grock
writing here?
Cuz I really don't see Grock writing any
code.
I see Grock running a bunch of
experiments and checking bugs and fixing
very very minor visual things and
inconsistencies
and loading bugs.
If you go back in YouTube as well,
you'll see um like three weeks worth of
me very very painstakingly refactoring
the core of Puffer down from 15k lines
all the way to 10k lines
because saving 5k lines of code was
worthwhile.
I'm still mostly using rock or whatever
while I'm refactoring stuff, but it's
not me just going refactor the code,
right?
It's much lower level line by line and
block byb block changes.
Yay! This one works.
Well, sort of works.
Cool. At least.
How long you been streaming on YouTube?
It only goes back two weeks. No, it
doesn't.
I'm going to be very very sad if that's
the case.
What do you mean it only goes back two
weeks?
It literally has all the VODs.
This thing literally has like 2,000
hours worth of streams, man.
You see this?
Look, this is from real world. It's like
eight hour eight hour stream.
Mine doesn't let me scroll past the two
weeks. Really?
That would be exceedingly weird to me.
They're definitely public
on mobile or something. Is it like some
weird thing?
Yeah, I've been doing this for what,
like threeish years now.
The refresh.
this is such a simple end, but it's so
satisfying.
I'll proceed stars. Of course, the
natural evolution of this one is this.
Please show chess.
Yeah. Let's see if this is fixed.
It's a little slow, but it works.
Probably just need to speed it up a
little.
Let me fix this first and I I will make
the chest thing faster. I don't This is
not one of the good policies though,
Cred.
Like this is just whatever quick
training run we happen to do for
testing.
trash
almost. It's just like long tail of
janky bugs, you know.
Well, we'll have to figure this out
generally.
It's Is this still slow-mo?
This is still slow-mo.
I I This is just like some ass mcriptton
web horseshittery.
Wait, wasn't that was Photoshopped,
wasn't it?
There's no way.
Well, yeah, obviously. Why would we use
that in selfplay?
Like, no. The goal is not to beat the
like the goal is not let's make the best
chess bot, right? The goal is like let's
see how far we can get with selfplay.
Yeah, let's make sure that we have our
drone end nicely working.
This is just Grock.
I It's not a product for me.
Fine.
Let's hopefully
have this stop screwing up our evals.
Would be very nice. And then I'm gonna
have to go through and see how much of a
mess it's made of all the different bits
of code associated with this.
So I'm hoping I will have two hours to
do before dinner and then we can have
this massive merge which has all the
fixed ends.
We can go from there.
Yeah, it's one of the annoying things
where it's like I really don't like
sitting here just having Grock open
doing all this stuff cuz it does send
set a very bad sign for the newbies. But
like at the same time, what do you want
me to do? I'm not implementing anything
right now. This is like stupid shitty
maintenance work that I have to do for
pre-release. Like obviously new people
aren't going to understand the
difference between that, but like this
is essentially generating very very
little new code. It's triaging a a large
number of small obnoxious bugs across a
whole bunch of environments. Half of
which are by contributors just vibe
coding the damn thing. So why am I
supposed to spend my time fixing them?
And then even though it's only a little
like small changes and stuff, I'm still
going to go through and review all the
diffs.
But like this bug for instance right
here, this is a bug we've dealt with for
the last two years. It's some utterly
stupid Mcryptton jank that has seemingly
irreproducible trigger conditions and
that you essentially just have to hack
around.
I'm not going to deal with this manually
for the fifth time.
The strategy you showed. what strategy I
showed the policy that was here was like
that I had here was not our good model
man. We have like I think a 1,200ish ELO
policy but this one wasn't it like this
is just the result of some random like
quick selfplay. It's probably that one
is almost random like random
performance.
If you want to see the real models, ask
Jess.
LMS,
are you watching that freaking PK event?
Volo.
That's crazy. We got the no boys allowed
PK event before raids 4.
Oh man, what were was it like the early
computer ads
or something?
annoying ebel bugs.
That's okay. Takes a little longer than
expected, but we will still have this
done tonight.
which means that uh Sunday
we get to test like usability and fix
any of the specific ends that we want
and then we are on track
for our Please.
excuse me. Okay,
at least finally
What is blown up
by 500 lines?
Puff roll is good. Algo is good.
Probably.
Yeah, puffer CPU even like this is just
Whatever the this is,
we'll fix that.
Oh, this is the full port. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah, this is the full port.
We'll be able to get through this pretty
quick.
I'm sort of just thinking how I'm going
to do all of these um these change
audits.
There's a restroom real quick, I think.
And then hopefully this will be done.
And then basically the plan is just
going to be to walk through all of the
ends one by one
and
we'll at least get the first pass in the
fixes.
Man, the bots on Twitch are getting
really weird. Are you diffing all
manually,
Sammy? They're going to be patterns of
bloat that um the LLM has added to all
the M's
where I'm basically going to go through
one by one with the LM like let's go
through the diff and I'm going to be
like up this is make like go
through all the M's and anywhere you've
done this undo it. I'll be right back.
I think it's bots.
Um, I don't know why anybody would be
doing this otherwise.
Okay, it did finish. So, that's nice. At
least
one second.
Yep. So, you see it like I find this
here.
This is going to be everywhere.
where the demos go.
I am currently going through env code
file by file and looking for like
bloated patterns from the LLM port.
And then I'm actually what I'm doing is
I'm like saying okay this is the fix. So
we fix it on the end that I'm looking at
and then I have the language model in
the background go apply the same fix to
any other ends where it made the same
porting mistake.
These are things like it added macro
guards on um on render and like
that.
Yep.
I see these stupid ones at the bottom.
It's pretty basic stuff. You see,
it's just like, oh, it wrapped the
functions for no reason. Cool. Um, like
let's just like for me, this is just a
quick delete. But we have 50 ms. You
could almost reex it, like almost, but
inevitably you're going to hit stupid
edge cases. It's way easier to just let
the thing go fix this type of error
everywhere. It's a completely brain dead
error, right, to fix.
And a lot of maintenance work looks like
this.
How much code do you think we delete
from kinverts five coded end There.
I mean, that's kind of the perfect use
for it, right? Is just like slightly
unfucking
completely vibecoded PRs.
It depends how automated we're talking.
If I go a couple passes in the loop and
I point out stuff that it missed,
I've done 30% before pretty easily.
Oh, let's see how bad this is for Kinber
Air.
So far, it doesn't look like it's even
done anything super aggressive That
We can do this on all the vibe coded M's
later.
I just kind of wanted to run it on one
to see.
I mean, like look at this. This
definitely
this is Joseph's stupid refactor
algorithm.
Inline everything only used once.
Eliminate defensive garbage.
Anything that's deeply nested. See if
you can invert some conditionals or
merge stuff to stop that
This one's the subjective one, which is
co-optimize multiconsumers
uh with the callers. This is basically
just like play around, see if you
actually split stuff up in the correct
way or not,
and then apply syntax and style at the
end. That's it. If you just do that a
couple iterations, like whether or not
the language model can actually do that
correctly is another story. Um, but if
you just do that yourself, that will fix
a lot of your code problems. That will
at least get your code from like
complete unreadable garbage crap to
decent starting point
on its own.
It's actually kind of funny what a
difference it makes just like literally
pasting together all your redundant
functions.
Doesn't look like it's actually um Oh,
no. It's cut down
150 lines at least.
Well, it's a language model. It
shouldn't have a personality. all day.
If this is the new code at 609 lines,
this is still super bloated. Good.
Okay. So, 779 starting. So, minus 168
lines of garbage.
Well, that just makes it like bad,
right? If the thing doesn't follow
instructions, it's just bad.
I mean the driving end is in use by
multiple companies. So
buffers on the road.
passing grade would be like
10 to 15%.
Well, it depends if what you mean. Me
just c if I can just casually like run
this stupid skill file on the thing and
just point out a couple obvious bits and
cut more than 10% off, it's a fail. If I
have if I like look at it a bunch and I
can eventually cut 10% off, like fine.
Oh, that's why it took so long. I had to
compact. Whoops.
Codeex is slow. That's why I'm using
rock.
That's the entire reason right there.
Can anybody explain to me why like
why this stupid compression thing does
exists?
Like why don't they just do a rolling
window of 500k tokens?
compression is not sparse attention
though
What do you mean pi dev?
Prime prime doesn't have a model, right?
wouldn't it be trying to retain contact
from earlier? Yeah, but it's just
summarizing it into a block of text and
then feeding it like it's not doing
sparse fancy anything.
Also, what the heck is happening with my
Let me make sure we're not crashing
again.
Me.
Rome's a little hungry, but other than
that, we're fine.
My rolling token window isn't a thing.
Do I?
To be fair, I don't know how much that
is Chrome's fault. Like, if you just
open Google Chrome to an empty HTML
page, how much RAM does it use?
Yeah, I it does. It still though, Volo
still doesn't m like Okay. 549.
So we just cut off like
did we just cut off a third of the code?
Pretty much we did, right?
And look now when I scroll through it, I
still see some defensive crap.
I still see a little bit of defensive
crap,
but way better, right?
Isn't that kind of funny how that works?
Why would you listen to Daario about
anything?
Wait - 62 and then what was it?
160 I believe.
So, it depends. If you make your N
really cool but bloated, I'll probably
just like auto clean it up enough that I
can play with it. If your env is like
kind of cool but really bloated, I'll
probably just ignore it.
If you want to waste my time, you have
to actually make something
This is a pre-language model, Zen, isn't
it?
Yeah, mostly a couple inverted diff
patterns is all.
Yeah. So Volo for instance, Valo Z is
really cool.
So VA I'll put up with a lot of
Sorry.
could have been like 500 instead of 600.
Not any less than that.
I mean, I believe that
hey, we have some runescape benge
though.
Uh, skill issues MD is just it's just in
the 50 branch now. I'm probably just
going to ship it without any comment.
All right, Jess. Yeah,
this is just going to be a giant push
with like all It's basically the
integration pass.
What am I working on?
We've got it pretty much all stable,
Jess.
All of them.
So now what I'm doing is I'm paying the
price for um just having LMS clean
everything up and I'm going through the
ends one by one with the model. I can
Nope. Stop that. Stop that. Stop that.
Obviously, I'm going to pay more
attention to M's that uh I think
actually have like a fair bit of
potential
I'm going to go to go get dinner in
about an hour and then I'm going to do
another night stream.
All right. So,
it get longer.
Oh, it did get longer, but it got longer
because we ported in the scripted stuff.
I'm fine with that.
620 lines.
Not bad at all.
iterating on Inferno on Monday.
Computer screen enough. I'll get it
pulled in. Thank you, Volo.
I'm still trying to think whether I want
to put the uh old school assets right on
the website or what I want to handle.
I might just do it and see if anybody
cares cuz like the color sim thing
exists, right?
Yeah, I agree.
The main problem actually will be how
big the assets are and whether we can
load them cleanly. Yeah,
like we need to bundle only the assets
that each one needs, I would think.
follow an employee. Nope.
open source contributor. There.
do Zoom all or something.
Do validate. Well, I don't need to
validate my contributors. It's like, are
you qualified to be contributing? I
don't give a I read the code,
though.
And yeah, I go over code. I'll like I'll
go over it live. If people want to go
over their code on Discord, I'll go over
code on Discord. If they want it
reviewed on live stream, I'll review it
on live stream.
If it's LLM crap, I'll flame them. If
it's bad, but it isn't LLM crap, I
probably will be nicer.
Reverse a link list.
Oh man.
Oh, that type of thing. Yeah, Jess.
That's um that's stuff like uh Kathy
Woo's lab does.
And if I recall, they have like some
really old Sims that apparently their
community trusts, but they're so slow.
to be fair, we could literally just pull
it from the Whimo data set.
We already have the fastest open- source
self-driving sim.
But I think just for a traffic control
end, it could be made significantly
simpler.
If I allocate 10 minutes to each env,
this is going to take about eight hours.
So I have to allocate less than 10
minutes per env.
Meaning that I need to have these start
being done in sub agents.
It's kind of funny how you can just
visually see the difference.
And then there's some debug stuff left
in here.
That's it.
I'll be right back to the restroom.
We'll do a little bit more of this and
then dinner.
What is reinforcement learning?
Learning through interaction.
So you have something taking actions in
an environment.
It starts off not knowing anything. It
takes random actions.
Bit by bit it learns.
We pair this with ridiculously fast
simulation
and we have neural nets that are playing
or like uh interacting on months of
simulations every second.
growth in RL going to be better than
LMS?
No. But I think it's going to be very
important
and I think it's going to be very very
embarrassing for AI as a field.
the amount of investment and time that
they've spent on language models
um and some of the problems that they're
trying to solve with language models
when they'll just get crushed with basic
RL using techniques from a decade ago
Oh. Huh.
Interesting.
Where did I do undergrad? Stanford CS.
So, I pretty much spent half of my
undergrad doing research anyways.
currently doing my masters. Learn more
about RL. What would you suggest is a
good starting point? I have educational
resources on just that.
and you just go to articles,
this is all of our research.
But then we also have educational
articles.
This in particular be very useful for
you.
High school student wanted to do CS at a
high level.
Well, start immediately.
Um, actually I I always like to respond
to these types of questions because I
really
I probably was too stubborn to have
listened to myself when I was in high
school. But this article, if I'd
actually listened to this and done what
this is, would have saved me many, many
thousands of hours.
Um,
like honestly like read this article
every couple of months or more often and
do what it says.
If you're brand brand new to CS and
don't know anything, I'd start with
Python. If you already have some
experience in some other language or
whatever, go right to C.
And then all the other stuff here like
seriously
I would also mention that um we have had
a couple different high school students
contribute simple environments to
PufferLib before. It is not outside of
the realm of possibility for relatively
new programmers, even without using like
a bunch of AI crap.
It just takes a little bit of time to
learn some fundamentals really.
And the thing is those fundamentals,
like that's kind of all there is. Um,
you don't need to learn a thousand
kicks. A lot of AI, a lot of CS and AI
education like here's a million things
you need to know. No, no, no, no.
They're like five things that you need
to know. That's it.
But you need to know them very well.
You need to be able to apply them in the
simplest way possible consistently
across a large range of problems.
Asian board are looking at international
masters
third world countries to study in the
US.
Well,
the biggest blind spot I've seen, um,
there's one guy I knew from Nigeria who
was brilliant, but couldn't get like he
couldn't even apply to MIT or anywhere
because they would require tests that he
literally couldn't take in his country.
Um, aside from that, they're generally
pretty good at accounting for like
background and such. And it's the same
thing as everywhere else ultimately,
right? exceptional ability.
Like the the thing is that most PhD
students have already done half of a PhD
or most good PhD students have already
done half of a PhD by the time that they
start.
Yeah, just come by. Stream is the
easiest way to find me. I'm stream like
I stream a lot of dev.
My general advice to new people though
is to like build a few things in Python,
but do not spend too long in Python.
It's nice because like you'll be able to
build a few things faster which will
kind of give you like some idea of the
types of things you can do. But like
ultimately
learning lowlevel is so incredibly
rewarding because you can just build so
many things and it's a little bit of
extra stuff to learn at first. But
actually it ultimately simplifies things
because if you don't know low-level dev,
there's so many other things that you
need to learn simply because the highle
languages are slow.
Whereas if you just write really dumb
low-level code,
like perf stops being an issue so much
more of the time.
Oh, hey John.
Wait. Hey John, where's uh where's my
fight caves PR? I want that end puffer
five.
Oh.
Valo got inferno and coliseum PRs up. We
got net hack PRs. I want my fight caves.
doing it right now. Awesome.
If you just get me like some sort of
working PR or like semi- workinging
version, I can get it integrated onto
five and we can start playing with it.
It seems like you really put a lot of
effort into like from what what you were
talking about earlier uh into the
quality of the overall engine
implementation
and that would make a lot of stuff
really easy to build on.
you know, like potentially depending on
how it looks, maybe it would be better
for Volvo to port um his Inferno and Ko
scenarios on top of your engine
because I know he put a lot of effort
into the individual scenarios
and the learning on those scenarios.
But engine might be dice Here.
very close to OSRS logic.
No, that's not a waste of time at all.
The engine has to match. Like
the mechanics have to be precisely
replicable
for uh for it to be usable.
Most of the bugs Volo has dealt with
have been like mismatches in the engine.
I'm not looking at this one cuz I know
that this is like pretty high quality
code already. This is Jess's stuff. Some
of the bank stuff is a little jank, but
that's because of legacy stuff. I'm not
going to mess with it.
There's so many M's. Jesus, we're only a
quarter of the way through.
Good news is there are a lot of just
like random whatever ends in here.
Oh, latest DRL class.
Is this actually good?
Offline to online
default final project.
Oh
yeah, this is real bad.
That's real bad.
Not. So we have not RL
RL RL
stupid baby mode RL and not RL.
So 40% RL and this is RL that doesn't
work.
Wait, is this ours
or is this Spencers?
This looks like I put my key on it.
Three days,
which is how long I've had this, right?
Note that I don't know how good the
modern versions of it are, but the
version I took all those years ago is
still perfectly good.
probably. Oh, we still have 20 people
watching the super slow dev stream
today. Hello, folks.
No, I don't.
Just the last couple days I have had a
box. The thing is, normally I have my
own boxes, but we've got some issues and
I have to be there in person to maintain
them.
when am I heading back to Puffer Farm?
I got a trip at the end of the summer,
so it still be a couple months. I'd love
to be back there, man. It's so nice.
Peace and quiet.
Okay, I'm good.
I got six hour logged.
A dangerous spot.
Yeah, it's east coast.
California is okay.
I don't know. It's been really brutally
hot for a lot of this summer.
what?
How the hell can this possibly be your
syllabus?
Hello.
Why are the courses bad? Well, half the
syllabus on these ar isn't even covering
like RL.
They miss all the actual important
things in RL and they spend all the time
on things that do not. and will not ever
work.
That's not bad.
It's like on par at least. I think this
is fine.
Luckily, most of these are already M
that I've reviewed.
See, a lot of the contributors actually
submit relatively reasonable stuff.
What happened to clean RL?
Oh, to chess RL. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So,
we have um we have chess. Uh it works.
We're still actively doing selfplay
research. We think that we're broadly uh
the main problem we have with selfplay
is just a general self uh a general
exploration problem. It's not really
anything specific to selfplay. So we're
kind of thinking about that. Next we
have other selfplay efforts in
development now trying to address that.
Uh the chess is like I don't know 1
1200ish 1100 1200 EL if you ask Jess I
think. Um,
and it we're definitely going to
continue using that end and trying to
push it higher.
university students entered in doing
under. Yep. The uh ML article on I have
a an article just for you on my website
xx.
This article, my highest rated piece of
content,
go for beats Google on the amount of
compute.
So,
the problem with trying to beat Google
is even if you make your stuff like
10,000 times faster than theirs, which
in several cases our stuff is literally
10,000 times faster than theirs, um they
will just spend 10,000 times the amount
of money.
But as far as our infrastructure and
stuff for RL goes, uh yes, we win quite
handily.
didn't use Google use them to play Atari
games.
Um,
we solved Breakout in under a second.
They're not hard.
Yes, you can force them to work by
spending utterly like ludicrous amounts
of compute.
They scale horribly
with data.
Uh they don't make effective use of SIM.
It's basically just RL being like stupid
and expensive and janky forever.
You can make it work by spending stupid
amounts of money, but it's very, very
jank and you're just never going to make
that stuff remotely compute efficient.
Puffer is not just faster because it
uses state vectors. Using state vectors
will get you your maybe your first like
factor of five performance over pixels.
Um, Puffer is not five times faster than
other things out there. It's over a
thousand times faster than other things
out there.
We can literally train over 50 million
steps per second on a single GPU.
And we can train like decent size nets
well over 10 mil SPS.
Like we can literally chew through over
a month of simulated data every single
second of training.
That's what happens when you ditch the
entire existing ML infrastack and build
your own from per for performance from
the ground up.
now. At least we're getting to ends that
are easy to deal with.
Eh,
couple style things, but it's a simple
end. There's not that much to screw up.
I guess
it does look a little long for what it
is.
What are you exploiting to get
everything like literally everything? We
have end to end CUD to C train stack. No
torch, no anything else. We have a
custom net architecture that is soda
over other recurrent nets that is much
more hardware efficient. We have fused
kernels for everything. We have stable
Bflat training. We have three axes of
parallelism during roll out inference
and training.
Like we have a lot a lot of stuff. Been
working on this for three years.
We literally solve problems that used to
take a day in a second.
entire thing goes away.
Um, I mean, you can train it against
like you can train it against uh other
cars that occasionally do wrong things
for robustness.
We do have, if you look at Puffer Drive,
right, this is
this is in collab with NYU,
this is the highest performance open-
source self-driving sim. It's used by
multiple companies.
loading the actual Whimo data maps. I
think there's Carla in it as well.
No, I'm done publishing. I finished my
PhD three years ago. I write blog posts
and I open source stuff.
Other than that, all my work is
professional.
Factorio would be very difficult.
You could probably get it to do
something.
Um, the observations and action space
for that game would be a total
nightmare, though.
It's kind of up to you whether you think
it's worth
setting that up.
Let me make sure that nothing messed
with the code for this. I've already
reviewed this end before.
No, it's kind of as I remember it. It's
not super high quality, but it's
serviceable.
No, NYU publishes lots of papers on
that.
Why do you open source? You make a
proper company.
Uh yes, Puffer AI is a company.
Businesses can hire us if they have
internal RL efforts or they have a
problem that they want RL applied to. We
build ultra high performance SIMs as a
service. We help companies integrate our
tools.
We do lots of things around the space.
Our stuff's open source so companies can
use it themselves. But of course, you
know, we're the ones who built it. So,
if you want to have the absolute best
chance of getting your problem solved in
the shortest amount of time,
we also do custom R&D stuff like this as
well.
I'm going to call it in a couple minutes
and get dinner. I'm getting hungry, but
I will I will be back after dinner for a
couple hours stream. Did you deploy Puff
Run hardware?
Um, there's one fun demo. Our intern
Finn has a drone that flies around his
room,
runs the puffer network, and you can
like shove it and stuff, and it just
goes right back to where it does.
Oh, yeah. I was on it for like the sim
work though. I didn't like help with
writing the paper
like Yeah. Spencer and I Spencer's on it
too, right?
That was a lot of work.
Childhood, you must have had a
portfolio.
Um, I mean, I've sort of been doing
research since I was like 16.
and I've been publishing since I was
like 19 maybe.
Pretty much spent half of my undergrad
doing research.
Like I did my main degree courses in the
first year and then I just did research.
Oh yeah,
big chunky an
Okay, so for our first refactor pass,
we've currently gotten through the this
column and then up to here. So, a little
more than a third of the way done.
We have a lot of M's in here that like I
don't need to look at.
So, arguably I think we're closer to
halfway done.
I'm pretty tired. I'm going to go get
myself some dinner
and then we're going to do a night
stream. I really want to have this
finished tonight.
Um Oh, wow. We have a lot of people
watching now.
Yeah. So the story with this for anybody
who's just joining us, um I'm trying to
get a stable release build of Puffer Lib
5, highest performance RL library out
there. A quite a big uh quite a big
margin. Do I have the uh all the ends
actually to show off? I don't. I'll pull
that web page back up later, but like
these are the ends that we had in Puffer
4. There many more of them in Puffer 5.
They are varying quality. They all need
audits at the very least, testing,
training, demos on the web. Um, it's a
lot of annoying janitorial type work,
which is why I'm kind of just hanging
out and doing a marathon stream this
weekend.
I think that by tonight we can have at
least gone through everything and make
sure everything is generally sane and
works.
I think that's going to be the goal.
If we can get that done, we can do
broader testing on the rest of the
library tomorrow. Make sure that nothing
broke in our trainer. Make sure our eval
setup is nice. Figure out any other
tools we want to do. Maybe look at
constellation a little bit. See if
there's anything we want to change
there.
And then hopefully we'll basically have
done all of the annoying pre-release
code side work in the course of one
weekend.
If we want to be extra ambitious, we can
also do documentation changes this
weekend.
There's actually not that much we have
to add to the docs. We very
intentionally have a pretty short docs
page. Other pre-release work is
typically we write a couple of blog
posts.
I'm probably not going to do that this
weekend. I'm going to wait until we're
actually ready to release for that. And
there are a few other just silly odds
and ends that we have to take care of
before I can fully release this.
But I I think that this will be a very
very good progress weekend. And if we're
in a good spot by Monday, I will do a
stream working on net hack because Finn
has some really nice net hack policies
and I think it would be interesting to
scale some of that stuff up. Oh yeah,
other ends that I we want to look at
before one uh before 50 releases fully.
Neural MMO 3, we found a big bug that
lets us get soda. We want to scale it up
and see if we can get Giga Soda. Um
Craftax and Craftex Classic both need
some major changes, but we have somebody
we're working with on those already.
I think that's all for now. I will be
back in about an hour and grab myself a
quick dinner, take a little bit of a
walk. I have been streaming for almost
seven hours. We'll put in another couple
hours this evening as a night stream.
Hopefully get through all the ends.
Tomorrow I will do uh probably like a
long run or something, some extra
exercise, and then I will still have
like pretty much the full day after that
to stream this. Thank you everyone for
tuning in. If you like my work, Star the
Puffer on GitHub. It's free. It helps me
out a lot. If any of this stuff looks
cool and you want to get involved with
development, join the Discord. It's
discord.gg/puffer
or click the button. And for all of my
RL content, including research and
education articles, you can follow me on
X